so does this now for me the evaluate
sign a plus B if sine a is equal to that
side B is equal to that and you've got
these two conditions on a and B
sometimes instead of this you might say
cm say I'm thinking radians by the way
you gotta start getting used to thinking
in rated the vast majority of trig stuff
in the C years is to do it not only that
but most of it between 0 and pi/2 or 0
and 90 degrees right what kind of egg
was that how would you describe its size
it's an acute angle right so
occasionally they'll tell you a and B
are acute now we'll come back to this
some domain restriction a bit later on
it seems a bit kind of like why are you
telling me this
but as we progress you'll see why I
heard alright now how would you solve
this if you didn't know trading stations
if you're a trader soon or anything like
you tend something like that what would
you do yeah okay all right now that's
interesting I think that's a tree
expansions approach when you just when
you talk to start oh yeah cause that's
the direction you're going in I think a
more basic simple way like you gave this
to a United yeah he likes to do what
would they do with this okay well if if
I gave you this question I just gave you
that piece of information right could
you tell me what a o is equal to
answered yes you could right what would
you do
you'd get your calculator out okay if
you've got a bad way
okay you get this out right and you
would say well you've heard about this
thing called sine inverse which reverses
what sign is right so if I take the sine
inverse of both sides slap one on this
side I'll get a right on the right-hand
side I'll get this and you get your
calculator out
and it tells you that's sine inverse of
that value now let's see just because
I'm talking to a year nine student right
so they didn't know what radians are and
besides it so hopefully get a bed right
here they've been tiered into a but they
might not understand radians are anyway
so just so you can get it into your head
this is crime tell me it's about thirty
six point nine degrees roughly is that
okay now you're like hey that's that's
approximate I can get my calculators to
know what that is exactly so you put it
into your calculator and you get it to
remember all the decimal places for you
right and you take the same logic and
you say well what's B then well again my
calculator tells me that it's about 16
point and then year nine you says that's
great that's all I need isn't it if I've
got a and I've got B then surely I can
work out sign a plus B okay thank you
stir kick up because your calculator
actually can do these exact values I'd
like you to do this now get what it is
and if you don't know how to do exact
values on your calculator here's what
you do when you press equals after this
right then your calculator should be
telling you it should say this on your
screen okay so you all these numbers
there right here's what you do the
button you're looking for probably looks
like this you see that button it simply
it's one of the small buttons at the top
okay so these the hands up if you got
that one yes okay most of you I got this
so they stand for store and recall story
recall
so what you want to do is you want to
press shift which i think is probably in
one of your corners right press shift
and then store and then you get to pick
a letter
now on this calculator here on top of
all of my little buttons I've got some
like pink or sort of dark red I wanted
letters there are letters there I just
used to write naughty messages on my
calculator anyway okay so there are real
purpose for this right chef is this I've
got ABCD up here which is very
convenient cuz I want a right so what
you need to do is press um the the key
which is a above it right which on my
calculator looks like this you see that
okay so I press shift store and then a
letter now then hopefully if you've done
it right on your arm on your calculator
display you know say that number and
then there's an arrow and it goes into a
who's who's seen that does anyone say
Matt yes okay so now this is really cool
if you want to get back to this letter
in the top left of my calculator there's
a button which is alpha so it's in alpha
for alphabet right so you reverse alpha
plus that button again right
don't let it hey you will appear and
you're like oh cool I can write messages
no way you'd actually do legit Matt's
with it okay sir
this a you want to do the same thing for
B okay can you get that I actually want
you to get that value okay so put this
value in a so then then clear it then
clear it redo your calculation so I
guess you'd say sine inverse of 7 over
25
yeah do one one go are you okay all
right to calculate this right this is I
wasn't gonna address this right now but
since you're forcing my hand okay
calculators are useful to school right
because they will do exactly what you
tell them to but if you tell them to do
the wrong thing they'll do exactly that
and they'll just they're just there
won't be you know useful tool they'll
just be okay so don't do that you're
just gonna get a wrong answer out of it
and you won't know cuz you like what the
calculator is into right so with
calculators you've always got to
minimize where errors can come in so I
always try and do this soup this
possible thing I can do my god all right
if you do it right then good for you and
you should be able to tell me the value
exactly is you mean you add up your
angle okay so tell me what's the sine of
that ah really yeah you like hold on a
second I spent all that time memorizing
that stuff with exact values and then
you come up with this and look at these
numbers like these numbers look really
weird and then when you add them up you
don't get some nice neat looking being
so where did this number jump out from
all right now magic okay so a couple of
things for starters I'm by the way by
this is exactly right that is exactly
the answer which you should end up with
okay so why don't we just do that when
you get a question like this okay number
one it shows no understanding okay like
seriously none of you can tell me why
it's for fits because my calculator said
sir and I trust my calculator okay it
doesn't show any understanding doesn't
show you how it works okay um number two
this this method it only works when and
be our excuse okay
if they are not acute they're obtuse or
reflux or anything else this method
breaks down and I will show you shortly
why that is
okay so number one it's it's it's an it
is magic actually it is no explanation
is it's a black box it just gives you a
number like okay okay
doesn't show any understanding number
two and only works in very specific
cases so I'm going to show you a method
which works whatever wherever these
things are okay